dans ce centre des restos du coeur de
plaisir on se prépare à distribuer plus
de 2800 repas cette semaine dominique
fait partie des 70 bénévoles de
l'antenne cela fait trois mois que cette
engagé en faveur des plus démunis
étant à la retraite vient on a quand
même beaucoup de temps au niveau donc
je me suis dit pourquoi pas aller au
resto donc je les ai rencontrés lors de
la fête des associations de plaisir et
puis deux jours après j'ai démarré au
pub de la distribution essentiellement
de la ramasse quand il ya des drames à
quimper à l'accueil un travail quotidien
pour cette retraitée de 64 ans cette
campagne hivernale est une première pour
dominique et si son rôle et logistique
il est avant tout humain au début c'est
difficile parce que il faut vraiment
avoir le coeur bien accroché votre
rencontre des katas même assez difficile
certaines personnes qui souffrent qui
ont suivi des idées des coûts de la
ville mauvais coups de la vie qui essaie
de s'en sortir donc on est là pour les
pour les aider pour discuter ne serait
ce que pour parler avec eux
des fois ils ont pas besoin ils ont même
discuté en besoin d'un contact social
ce contact social c'est aussi rené qui
leur offre il s'occupe de l'accueil à la
personne et des inscrits les idiots
demandeurs d'emploi demandeurs donc
simplement le csa les raisons mon fils
on les aide au point de vue alimentaire
mais on les aide aussi au point de vue
administratif
lorsqu'on va inscrire les gens on va
voir s'ils ont tous leurs droits
je veux dire par exemple l'aide médicale
d'état ou la cmu c
les réductions transports toutes les
aider à régulariser leur situation
[Musique]
recherche d'emploi on a des gens qui
sont un peu spécialisé dans la recherche
d'emploi faire un cv à établir un fait
écrire avec les gens franchir la porte
des restos du coeur une étape difficile
pour les personnes en situation précaire
qui souvent n'osent pas venir mais rené
a l'habitude de les rassurer
il a rejoint l'association dont les
années 90 et était même président
départemental en 1998 j'ai un engagement
très riche beaucoup de janvier à mars et
parce que vous donner mais on reçoit
beaucoup enrichissant surtout celle de
la moitié 60 ans donc ça donne quand
même beaucoup de
on a l'impression d'être utile et faire
quelque chose quand on n'est pas dans
notre fauteuil à regarder tes et je
pense que ça fait pour l'esprit pour la
personne même pour avenir pour la
suspendre que pour la santé aussi
important pour le moment près de 150
familles sont inscrites dans ce centre
de distribution de plaisir durant la
campagne elle devrait être 250 en france
près de 9 millions de personnes vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté
les restos du coeur cherche toujours de
nouveaux bénévoles